-Charlize, you've been in
some giant, giant movies,
you've won an Oscar,
but the "F9" --
these "Fast and Furious" movies,
it's massive.
The audiences, the fans
are just so passionate.
When did you realize,
like, "Oh, this is --
I'm stepping into
a whole universe here."
-Yeah, I mean, listen,
I -- I'm not --
It's hard not to know
just how impressive
these movies are,
and it's -- it's -- to step into
it is intimidating already,
just because of what
they've built
and have kind of nurtured
over the years.
And people love these movies,
and they love
these characters deeply,
and the whole theme of family
runs so deep
in this franchise.
So, when I when I showed up
as the baddie in "Fast 8",
and kind of like,
you know, turned Dom,
Vin Diesel's character,
against his family
in that -- in that movie,
I definitely had
a couple of fans --
It was like this -- like,
they appreciate a good villain,
but at the same time
they were like,
"How dare you do that to Dom?!
How dare you turn him against
the family?!"
And so it's like --
-Yeah, you don't mess with
the family!
-Yeah. It's always, like,
"But great job.
We want a good baddie.
But don't do that again."
I'm like, "Alright,
I won't mess with the family."
-And now you have to -- you have
to intimidate John Cena
in this movie,
who is a pal of ours,
and he's -- he's Dom's brother
in this movie.
What's it like
working with Cena?
-Oh, my God,
he's just so incredible.
I could not have asked
for a better scene partner.
-He's funny, too.
-I was pretty exhausted
coming off "Old Guard" --
like, it was two days after
that shoot,
which was a pretty long shoot.
I was pretty bruised up.
I was just, like --
And then I was, like,
put in this box
and I had all this dialogue,
and I definitely had
a couple of moments
where I was struggling
with my lines,
and this guy was just so, like,
right there.
At some point -- At one point,
he, like, knew the line
that I missed and I was like,
"This guy, like,
he even, like, knows
the line that I just missed."
Like, just there supporting.
-He's a pro!
-He's funny and --
Yeah, and he's great.
In the film,
he plays Dom's brother
and they have a lot of kind of,
like, unfinished business,
which is --
which is pretty cool.
-Yeah. I want to show everyone
a clip from the movie.
Here's Charlize Theron
in "F9". Take a look at this.
-East L.A. is a tough
enough place to grow up...
but it was your brother's shadow
that turned you into this,
isn't it?
♪♪
So your whole life, you pushed
yourself to be faster than Dom,
smarter than Dom,
stronger than Dom.
Tell me, do you hate him enough
that it keeps you up at night?
♪♪
Still?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Who is better than
Charlize Theron?
Charlize Theron,
everybody.
"F9" is in theaters today.
Check it out.